-Our first guest tonight,
is a Daytime Emmy-winning
talk show host
and actress who you can
see weekdays on
"Live with Kelly and Ryan."
Her book, "Live Wire:
Long-Winded Short Stories"
is available now.
Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend
Kelly Ripa, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hello, Kelly.
-Hello.
That was exciting, Fred.
Oh, my gosh.
-I know, right?
Having Fred here
is a big deal for us.
Yes, very big deal.
-It's a big deal having you here
as well,
because we hold you in very high
regard in these parts.
You were a week one guest with
"Late Night with Seth Meyers."
And that means a lot to us
that you came here when we
were just getting started.
-Guess what?
You have been very
instrumental in my life.
And I am always here for you any
time you want me, day or night,
24/7.
-Thank you.
I can deliver your next baby.
Whatever you want.
-Oh, that's so ---
You know,
I'm glad you mentioned that.
Because when our second child --
when our first child was born,
you sent a very conventional
and lovely, I should say, baby
gift.
And then our second son
was born in the lobby
of our apartment building,
and you sent catcher's mitts.
-Yes.
-My wife misunderstood the humor
in that gift.
-She did. She wrote me this
funny note saying,
"Oh, dear Kelly --" the most
gracious, I mean, you have --
-She is a very wonderful person.
-She is so wonderful.
And, like, you send a gift,
and a thank you note
arrives the next day.
And you think, was she waiting
for this gift?
"Dear Kelly, I thought it was so
funny that you thought
Seth would ever take our son
to play catch."
And I was like --
[ Laughter ]
No, that's to catch
the next baby...
-Yeah.
-...when the baby -- because
they just fall out.
-They do just fall out.
It is funny that she loves --
the thank you notes
she writes first are the ones
where she can slam me
in the middle of the night.
-Exactly.
-Those are the ones
she's very eager to write.
Those are the most important
thank you notes.
Thank you for the man
that did this to me.
-Speaking of kids, you and Mark,
your wonderful husband --
empty nesters.
I can't believe it.
We're kind of empty nesters.
And then my mom had heart
surgery,
so now we're
living with my parents.
-Okay. Wow.
And Mark's like,
"That didn't take long."
-Yeah.
The nest is full again,
but with older people."
-What happened to our nest?
-Our nest is --
Well, that's very sweet
that you would
create a nice home for them
at this time.
Oh my gosh, we love, I mean,
we love -- we love
collectively
all of our parents.
And we appreciate that they
fall apart in different stages.
Like, yeah.
-Right.
So it's not like they're all
with us all at once.
It's like first my Mother-in-Law
will have surgery.
Then my Father-in-Law
Then my Dad has surgery.
-It's nice when they stagger it.
-They stagger the surgeries.
-It's very sweet they do that.
-They're thoughtful
elderly people.
-So you wrote this book,
and this is
a collection of essays,
but you know, personal
essays about your life.
What inspired you to do it?
Was it easier than you thought
it would be? Harder?
-It was ten times harder than I
thought it would be.
I thought because
I read books --
-Sure.
The thought process was,
"I read books,
so how hard can it be?"
-You know right after page two
comes page three.
-Yeah, it's really hard
to write a book.
-It's hard.
But as hard as it was to write
the book,
and it was brutal.
I'm not kidding.
There were days where I'm like,
"God, I'm such a crap typer.
I'm just gonna write it
free hand."
Because the ideas are getting
away from me
faster than I can
get them down on the page.
The hardest part about all of
this, now that it's done,
is, like, going out and selling
a book feels,
I don't want to
understate this,
it feels so gross.
I mean, like --
-Well, it's interesting,
right, because, yes,
especially when it's
a book about yourself...
-Right. Exactly.
-...because you're saying
yeah, if you like what I'm
saying right here,
there's more in here.
-There's more in here.
If you like all of this, wait
until you read this.
-But the interesting thing, you
know,
to go back to Mark,
you're obviously,
you write about
how you guys met.
You also note that, you know,
you're still happily married,
but he has different memories
about everything.
He has no memories
about anything
because men have an ability
to turn off their memory.
And I am like an elephant.
I wander around
just gathering memories
that I wish I could forget.
-Weighing you down.
-It's weighing me down.
No, it's really --
it's like a very --
like I told you back stage
I said, "Can't we just come out
here and talk about
'I'm not scared, you're scared."
-My children's book. Thank you.
Because I'd rather
talk about your book.
-I think everybody
can go out and buy it.
We don't have to talk about it.
-Guys --
-We don't have to talk about it.
-Guys, we don't want to brag,
there's a bundle deal.
If you buy both books,
you get a discount.
-You do talk about --
so you met Mark on
"All My Children."
-I met Mark on "All My Children"
in such a way that today,
in this atmosphere,
this climate,
that we all live in,
I basically,
accidentally, innocently,
sexually harassed my husband.
-Okay.
Very big of you to admit.
-Yes, well, I admit it right
there on the page.
I walked up to him at a screen
test and I said,
"I had a dream about you
that we --"
I know. At that point,
he should have hit the button
and they would just take me out.
-Right.
-But I said, "I had a dream
about you.
We were on a plane together
to Rome and we had a baby.
The baby was wearing
red feeted pajamas."
And he's like, "Oh, yeah?"
[ Laughter ]
Like, he's looking around at
the other guys that are
screen-testing like, "Has she
said anything bat[bleep]
like this to any of you?"
[ Laughter ]
And the other guys
are all listening.
And he goes, "Oh, have you ever
been to Rome?"
And I said, "No, never."
And he goes, "Oh, we used to
live in Italy.
You would like it." Not knowing
me at all. And he walks away.
He walks away probably
to file a restraining order.
[ Laughter ]
And then I was like,
"who is we? Who is we?"
-Right, when "we" used to
live there.
-Yes, so I made it my mission
to figure out who "we" was.
-Uh-huh.
-Meaning his parents
and his siblings.
-Yeah.
-Because he was seven.
[ Laughter ]
But I thought he had a wife.
-He goes, "I have a dream that
one day,
they're going to be
living with us."
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly.
-"You'll love them."
-"And I think you're the girl
to make that dream come true."
[ Laughter ]
-You also talk about how
this business, that I'm sure is
true of all businesses,
but how much this business
has changed for women...
-Yes.
-...over the course of your --
at this point, very, you know,
you've had a long career. You've
been in this for a long time.
How do you feel --
What is your main takeaway
for how much it's changed?
-I think it's -- any change
incrementally -- it always seems
so slow, right?
Change seems glacial.
But when I think back to when
I was starting out, you know,
lucky for me I wasn't fired for
sexually harassing my husband.
But seriously, it was very hard
for women to advocate
for themselves in any way
in terms of pay equity
or having appropriate office
space or being given appropriate
breaks that were so readily
available to the men.
So I think those changes that
sort of just happen now,
people forget there was a time
and a place,
in the not too distant past,
where that was considered
like some form of
insubordination.
-Yeah, to ask for those things.
-"I have to nurse my baby.
Can I take a break?"
Like, "Again?!
How many times a day
does this kid eat?"
-And then you have -- I will say
as someone who has kids,
they eat all the time.
-All the time.
They're like energy vampires.
-They are energy vampires.
Speaking of, I, to this day,
remain amazed by your energy.
It is always so great to see you
on television.
Even nicer to see you in person.
Thanks so much for being here,
Kelly.
-Thank you.
I'm so happy to see you.
-Kelly Ripa.
"Live Wire: Long-Winded
Short Stories" is on sale now.
We'll be right back with
Fred Armisen,
Ana Fabrega and Julio Torres.